right good good evening like gentlemen
correct - let's get started first of all
to the emergency fact evacuation
announcement should be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest of
both available exit to the chamber one
there and one there 70-point will in the
public car parked and the side of the
city office I see it sweet please do not
delay your evacuation to collecting
Burak beelines
please do not return to the building and
to given permission to do so by council
staff please note that this meeting will
be audio recorded and can I ask that
mobile phones are switched off or placed
on silent Elise
tell me following my path from the
Conservative Party I have not received a
formal written response with regards to
my seat on the Investment Board also on
Cena's within the council I am still
registered as an ending the sperm wolf
committee member I have taken advice on
that counselor I'm advised that because
the seat is a conservative seat because
you'll no longer a member of the
conservative group does that see it
becomes vacant that's the advice I've
been you move on to item one apologies
for absence I have councillor Stanley
and council of Gooding substitute papers
I have counselor mr. Shaw for capsule of
good okay
normal members attending got quite a
list if you'd like to put your hands up
okay okay at this point just before we
go on to the minute I'm going to ask
touches to address the committee thank
you Kay I want to say a few words
because I know that members are
concerned while they're having this
meeting but it was helpful intersex is a
beginning and so that members could be
appraised advice there suite of NASA
feedback there cause the starting point
is that government has not advice
counsel to stop in meetings
indeed actually important to the nor we
have no option in order to make a
decision to have these have to be done
blind face-to-face meetings so we are
taking a risk approach as including
slave government guidelines and
influence with it I exist by the
Minister for Communities and housing in
local government that said that
necessary council business should be
transacted reviewing all of our agendas
going forward in the light of evolving
department advice this is in fact
unnecessary meeting because it is the
next step in a complex legal process
which has taken that in excess of 12
months to get to this point the decision
that members are being asked to make
tonight which is to refer the matter to
the council towards the end of the month
reliving all the council to move forward
in that legal prayer and to be
commercial certainty to the bidders who
are part of that process if we are not
able to make that decision or call
Council on the 26th then we won't have
to cross that vision as
come true but actually creates a legal
uncertainty and a commercial Lubo for
bidders it's important to remember
members that this evening is not about
making a decision to award it is a
decision to go simply to the next stage
in the procurement process in the
expectation for Council will then follow
the recommendation this of this
committee the 26th of March if I would
say if for council it cannot happen you
can need to be debates in soviets that
we need to add on when we can you should
ensure that we are progressing business
as usual i hope that helps thank you
okay item for you who have received a
minute so that's me in light of what has
actually been brought to us this
afternoon by prime minister they were
has categorized the situation that we
were in at the moment is unprecedented
if we are in a time when we're gonna
have to make some difficult decisions
some of the allowances that the Prime
Minister has come up with this afternoon
is the freezing of payment of business
rates I'm a quick calculation I reckon
the based and leave the council shortly
two point three mr. Costa what's US
business rates got to do with this
meeting it is known to affect the risk
of this council huge it's not relevant
to this meeting
yes it is because it should where our
risk register has not been updated and
for this project and that is part of the
risk that is involved with this project
okay with respect that should be done
before we proceed any further
check if I can come back on that the the
the evolving advice is being followed on
a daily if not hourly basis the
situation in relation to the decision is
being asked to be made tonight he's not
a wonderful Ward so it's not about
making a contractual decision you simply
about ensuring the next stage in the
legal process so in relation to updating
our both our corporate register and the
product list register than clean that is
absolutely a function of the project
teams will continue on post this evening
this decision and until such time as the
project comes to fruition so that is an
ongoing ongoing situation I would just
commit through the line members that and
govern even happening at Pace and we
understand that the minister is working
with the Cameron office to draft a new
legislation which will enable meetings
to be conducted virtually but until such
time as I that legislation is passed by
Parliament we have no option but a
face-to-face meetings take it thank you
okay back to four you've had copies of
the minutes of the meeting held on the
5th of September 2019 can I have your
agreement that they are a true record
reckless greed
I took isogenic Buyten five to receive
direct declarations of interest already
okay if everything should come up during
the meeting can I rely members to let me
know at that particular point yes okay
just before we start on item six
I will remind members and members of the
public that part of this meeting will be
going into P&C private accommodation at
which point I'm sorry to say I'll go
through the appropriate notice at that
point but at that point I will have to
ask members of the public to leave other
than two we have two visiting people
with us here today
Duncan Blacky and Andrew Rosen both of
the East of England Local Government
Association who have been part of this
particular project
so how do you agree somewhere thank you
okay so I will remind members also as
well
I will ask members to refrain from
asking questions until the whole
presentation has been gone through right
at the very end it is quite lengthy I do
apologize for that but we will take
questions at the end I will take
questions from each member of the
committee in turn and also as well
within consider taking questions from
visited members but please refrain from
making any statements or announcements
or anything else like that because it
will just be questions okay so we'll
move on to item six and I believe the
portfolio holder is going to pick off
the
Thank You general mantra District
Council is pursuing an ambitious and set
strategy with the following objectives
to reduce future costs which must be in
the interests of council taxpayers to
regenerate the local area and facilities
for local residents and businesses
across the whole of the Rockford
district and to provide fit for purpose
office accommodation for council staff
and key partners in order to drive
efficiencies through a digital first
wave of working in January 2019 the
investment board and council approved
the output business case to deliver on
these objectives and bring the strategy
into reality
the Essex strategy is just part of a
wider transformation program on the way
in which the council operates since I
became portfolio holder for Enterprise
last year I have had a clear vision of
an optimized asset base that is fit for
purpose enabling quality service
delivery for residents and visitors
through a sustained program of
transformation from now and for many
years to come the Civic built suite
building and the mill arts and Events
Center in Raley have served as well but
they are now hired buildings
I am personally committed to retaining a
proportionate civic presence in Raley
which will provide facilities to support
businesses and residents of the town as
well as touchdown that facilities where
outreach officers of the council can
meet with residents of the town or from
where they can work remotely equally the
council is committed to continue to
provide accommodation to its community
partners Rockford and Rayleigh
Association of voluntary service
roads open adult counseling services and
citizens advice as well as the groups
clubs and individuals who hire space in
the mill arts and events center for
various important community activities
in Rockford our current offices are
expensive to maintain and put simply and
just not fit the purpose our staff
deserve better average that's who visit
them deserve better myself and the
member working group have been quite
clear from the outset with the civic
pride which residents have in our
community facilities their historical
settings and in particular the need for
attractive modern facilities for public
higher is vital for the design of any
future building this is indeed reflected
in the output specification that has
already been approved by members I would
like to reassure members that a program
of community and stakeholder engagement
working as a partner to this council is
something we have asked bit bidders to
provide and put money aside to achieve
so engagement about our plans will be
meaningful detailed and a two-way belong
to a long before we even get to a
planning stage I hope that residents and
councils
counselors across the political divides
and across the district will get on
board and sharing my passion and
enthusiasm of the exciting vision of the
future which I suggest will be far
superior to what we currently have
before I pass over to councilor sparing
can I take this opportunity to thank
very sincerely members of the working
group all Rockford district council
officers under the leadership of map
Albert white and all our consultant
partners for the tremendous support and
commitment you are giving to this
thank you catch it's very basic thank
you so Jared members of the investment
board the following clouds Thornton's
comments and in supporter of council
offices comprehensive statement
regarding the asset delivery program
which will be presented shortly I offer
this statement on behalf of the council
members who supported and were involved
in the working group in 2018 assets that
strategy agreed that doing nothing I
just keep going on as we were now with
minimum investment was not an option
when we when faced with the increasing
midterm financial strategy budget gap
and our continuing commitment to provide
value for money services to our
residents the our business case
identified that the preferred option was
economically advantageous than to do
minimum auction since the council would
be exposed to the costs of running and
maintaining the mill arts and Events
Center and the freight house when the
leisure contract ends in 2022 plus the
costs of repairing and maintaining the
aging Civic suite and South Street
offices the preferred option agreed in
here on business case proposed a program
of integrative projects redevelopment of
the freight house as the council's
long-term office accommodation and civic
space redevelopment of the middle site
to create a new building community
facility alongside new houses commercial
and mixed uses and redevelop South
Street sites specific suite for housing
commercial or mixed uses the preferred
option was set out in the outline
business case which was approved by the
Investment Board on 16th of January 2019
and then by for council on 19th of
February
20:19 the council then began the
procurement process to explore House
bill give up the preferred option the
council members on the working group
have been a fundamental part of the
process which was set up under specific
terms of reference to work with officers
professional advisors and the portfolio
holder to see this project through at
the start of this project it would hope
there would be cross-party involvement
in the working group but regrettably
this opportunity was not accepted and
only myself and councillors FD Lukas Gil
and Williams served on this group as a
group we have had to work through a very
strict people procurement process which
has been completely new to many of us
and at times has been very frustrating
but this process was strictly followed
the Treasury best practice we have also
built in external experts which have
included experts in the field of project
management legal financial and technical
these officers are Vittoria B's experts
have work fully with officers and the
members of the working group in February
9 2019 a local partnership health check
review endorsed our approach and
validated the decisions taken to date at
that time we have also had additional
assurances through the East of England
LGA who were commissioned specifically
to provide critical friend support to
the members working group and have been
part of the procurement process
throughout the member working room is
confident that the process has been
member days and has been robustly
managed we have confidence in the
solutions which have been put forth by
the preferred bigger bidder we can't
talk about the specifics of the
solutions and to a meeting moves to
PNC's but we believe that them as the
member working group we have done all
that was asked of us a key decisions
have been passed for us
and their arms a formal council
governance an investment board or full
Council or both finally there is still
more legal process to be completed but
once this has been done the member
working group has been clear that the
council will begin to engage with public
and stakeholders such as users of the
building about these proposals in the
procurement process the council
specified that the preferred bidder
would work with us to ensure that this
period of engagement was right
wide-ranging and meaningful we want to
know what residents think of the
solutions and hear their feedback they
may want to give all this will be in the
past at the formal planning consultation
so it was a real opportunity to
influence the final proposals the
members of the working group are happy
to talk in more detail about the
preferred it''s solution but we must
move into PSC to do that as I mentioned
earlier much of this process has been
very frustrating for members of the
working group because we have not been
permitted to answer questions from both
both councillors and residents but it is
very important that we continue to study
P and C until the legal process has been
completed because otherwise the entire
procurement process could be jeopardized
leaving the council exposed to
potentially huge legal claim we are
pleased to be able to bring this report
forward and ask the Investment Board to
approve the recommendations set out
there thanks Perry I'd like to add my
thanks to the working party not working
group I know how much work and how much
time they have put into this dealing
with this I can't thank them enough and
I think and I hope other members will
agree with me once you see the
presentation they've done an excellent
job and really have our stone searching
questions that were needed to be us
at this point I needed to go into I need
to go into P and see a real will read
the exclusion resolution members the
public the following report contains
exact information and I would therefore
ask you to leave the meeting it is
hereby resolved that under Section
hundred in brackets a in brackets for of
the Local Government Act 1972 the public
be excluded from the meeting from the
following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information as
defined in paragraph three of part one
of the schedule 12 a of the Act members
happy that the public would have to
watch each one page six point one zero a
she's got the little the way okay okay
well let's move on anyway I'm assuming
that there is anybody out there
okay we've got a number of
recommendations on 6.10 page six point
one zero item fourteen point one I'll
take age into recommendation in in order
one at the time I would like a show of
hands for each and as we go through so
I'll read them out and if you can give
me a show of hands let's go item
recommendation one to recommend to for
counsel that the outcome of the
procurement process set out in the
tender report be approved
it's which is the exempt appendix one
those in favor those against any
abstentions on obsession item two to
recommend to for counsel that the
preferred bidder is set out in the
tender are set out in the tender and
reporter exempt appendix one be
appointed for the asset delivery program
does he favor that's the Menace to
recommend to item three to recommend for
counsel that the final business case
except exempt pendeks to to be approved
as you favor any against new sanctions
item four to recommend to for counsel to
delegate authority to asset director
director assets encumber so it's target
to recommend to for counsel to do get
delegated authority to the assistant
director assets and commercial and
conducts up with the portfolio holder
for enterprise to enter into
negotiations with the preferred media
identify to confirm financial
arrangements and other other terms
contained in the tender report and the
FS f b8 c and report back to the full
counsel for final approval those in
favor and against any abstentions
item five to recommend to for counsel
that seventy two thousand five hundred
pounds of unspent project budget be
carry Ford to the twenty 2021 and to
agree the additional budget of two
hundred and fourteen thousand nine
hundred pound to be funded from the hard
soft infrastructure reserve to fund the
resources required to process the
program during 2021
those in favor against any abstentions
okay
Thank You counselors that brings the
meeting to a close thank you to the
officers for attendance and thank you
the visiting members for attending and
please I must remind you that watch
apparently today is P and C and